[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ومرحبا المشاهدين الكرام الى
فقرات
عند ضعفي تمثيليه المراه التونسيه كمرشحه
في الانتخابات التشريعيه المقبله والمقر
الاجراءات ال17 من شهر ديسمبر المقبل مع
ضيفتي مشاهدينا الكرام عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه من تونس العاصمه السيده احلام
بسروال الكاتبه العامه لجمعيه التونسيه
للنساء الديمقراطيات سيد احلام وسروال
اهلا بك ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك على تربيه
هذه الدعوه
مساء الخير كل الشكر مرحبا بك مرحبا وانت
ايضا بضيفتي في الجانب المقابل دائما من
تونس العاصمه عبر الاقمار الصناعيه السيده
ليلى حداد المحاميه والقياديه في حركه
الشعب السيده ليلى حداد اهلا بك ايضا
وشكرا جزيلا لك على تلبيه الدعوه
مرحبا اهلا وسهلا
هيئه الانتخابات التونسيه
201858 ملفا للترشح لهذه الانتخابات
البرلمانيه المقبله تتوزع بين
936 رجلا ومئه واثنين
و20 امراه يتنافسون جميعا على مئه وواحد
161 مقعدا في البرلمان حسابي انا الان
حظوظ الرجل
التونسي في نيل منصب في البرلمان اكبر سبع
مرات من حدود المراه التونسيه وسؤالي ما
تعليقكم على ذلك معك اولا سيد احلام
بسروال الكاتب العامه للجمعيه التونسيه
لنساء ديمقراطيات اهلا ومرحبا من جديد
شكرا على الدعوه
122 امراه فقط
في البرلمان القادم ليست هناك سبع حظوظ
للرجال وانما هم في 90% حدود للرجال على
النساء مع كنا منذ ايام في الجمعيه
التونسيه النساء الديمقراطيات تظهرنا امام
الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات
رفضا لي همم التحوير لتحويل القانون في
علاقه بالقانون الانتخابي وكان احتجاجا من
على التراجع على التناسق هذه الارقام
اليوم كانت منتظره كانت منتظره لانه وقع
التراجع على التناسب اليوم همم امام
العالم تونس لا تتراجع فقط على التنصف
وانما تتراجع على المشاركه السياسيه
للنساء طيب وغدا
فتكون نعم سناتي ربما عن همم
سيد همم
ان تونس غدا سوف تعرض تقريرها التقرير
الدوري الشامل همم بتاريخ 8 نوفمبر وسوف
يكون للمجتمع المدني الكثير ليقوله حيث
انه تجاوزت التقارير همم
الموازيه للمجتمع المدني في علاقه بمجلس
همم مجلس حقوق الانسان اكثر من سنين و40
تقريبا
والجمعيه التونسيه النساء الديمقراطيه مع
الديناميكيه النسويه قامت ايضا بتقديم
تقرير موازي تطالب فيها تكريس مبدا
التناسق وبدعم المساواه ودعم النساء في
القاهره وسناتي على مستقبل هذه
الديناميكيه النسويه لمعرفه ما اذا كانت
مهدده بالنسبه همم اذهب الى ضيفه السيده
ليلى حداد المحامي والقياديه في حركات شعب
كما تبعتي نسبه مشاركه المراه المرشحه
لهذه الانتخابات البرلمانيه بلغ احد عشر
ونصف في المئه فيما يوصف اليوم في تونس
صيدليه حداد بانه اول تراجع لافت بعد
الثوره على مستوى المشاركه النسائيه
وتمثيلها في البرلمان المقبل مقارنه
بالانتخابات السابقه من يتحمل مسؤوليه ذلك
ما تعليقك على ذلك نحن امام قطيعه مع
نسويه الدوله
لا اعتقد ذلك لان المؤشرات تراجع المراه
وحضور المراه كياديه في الاحزاب السياسيه
او في البرلمان او حتى في السلطه
التنفيذيه كوزيره هناك تراجع كبير منذ
2014 الى حدود 2019 حيث كانت المراه في
سنه 2014 الى حدود تواجدها بالبرلمان الى
حدود 35% ثم تراجعت في 2019 الى حدود 23%
فقط وكذلك تراجع حتى في نسبه تواجد
الوزراء في الحكومات بالنسبه للمراه في
سنه 2019 الى 16%
وهذا التراجع دليل على ان التشريعات ليست
فقط هي التي ممكن ان تعطي حظوظ للمراه بل
كذلك هناك العديد من العوامل همم اعتبيرها
عوامل الموضوعيه وهي الاراده السياسيه وهي
هل ان هذه التشريعات وصلت المجتمع وكانت
المراه تدافع حقوقها كمواطنه تونسيه لها
نفس الحقوق والواجبات مع الرجل ام انها
مجرد ضحيه تبقى في همم متناول القضايا
ويجب من يدفع بها الى الامام عبر
التشريعات اعتقد ان هذا التراجع كذلك يرجع
الى نوعيه هذا القانون الذي القانون
الانتخابي الجديد والتنقيحات التي وصلت
اليه باعتبار اننا لم نعد نتحدث عن قانون
انتخابي فيه قائمه حزبيه او قائمات كذلك
مستقله وانما نتحدث عن الترشح على الافراد
وبالتالي هناك همم عزوف من المراه
التونسيه لنقل في الترشح في همم
الدوائر الانتخابيه وهذا العزوف همم اكيد
لو نطرحه اليوم فهناك العديد من العوامل
خاصه منه المناخ الانتخابي وهمم درجه
وارتفاع نسبه العنف السياسي في تونس الذي
لاحظناه في 2019 مره من الت طيب وخاصه على
المنصات التواصل الاجتماعي هذا من الجوانب
التي ادت الى عزوف المراه وعدم رغبتها في
المشاركه السياسيه همم شكرا سيدي ليلى
حداد سيد احلام بوس سروال الكاتبه العمل
جمعيه التونسيه انسات ديمقراطيه ضيفتي
تتحدث عن تراجع تمثيليه المراه تقول انه
ليس حديثا تتحدث حتى عن عزوف من المراه عن
الترشح واخرون يدافعون على الرئيس الذي
يحمله البعض همم المسؤوليه في اضافه
تمثيليه المراه الان في هذه الانتخابات من
خلال الترشح يقولون ان الرئيس عزازه في
عهده اعلى تشاركه للمراه التونسيه في
الحكم اخرون يقولون ايضا ان قاعده
المساواه بين المراه والرجل متوفره في
القانون الانتخابي الجديد القانون لم يفرض
الرجل بايه امتيازات همم على حساب المراه
همم او اكثر او اقل من المراه وذلك بوضع
شرط التزكيات ل- الجنسيه كيف تردين على
ضيفه صيدليه حداد المحامي والقياديه في
حركه الشعب
هناك علاء هناك مستويات المستوى الاول ان
التشريعات لا تعزز بلا تعزز ما جعل السيده
ليلى حداد ان تكون نائبه سابقا هو التناسق
هي القوانين هي المراكمات للحقوق
الانسانيه للنساء هي النضلات نسويه من اجل
التناصف التشريعات هي من اوصلت صيدليله
حداد وعديد النساء الى الى القرار الى
المشاركه في الحياه السياسيه
من الحكومات ولكن النسبه اخر نسبه اخر
برلمان كانت 26% وترى واحد الى اكثر من
26% في عديد المرات تجاوزت حتى 35% اذا
اذن 35% و26% نحن اليوم امام قديش فصل
الخمسه بالمياه كم مرشحات وليس
يعني رقم صافي نهائي لوصول للمشاركه نعم
نحن نتحدث عن فرق كبير
قديش فصل 5% يعني لن تصل النساء
لاكثر من 8% مستحيل بهذه النسبه لم تصل
اكثر من 8% وهو سوف يكون رقم كيريفي
تاريخي هذه النقطه الثانيه قبل النقطه
الثانيه عفوا لماذا كارثي منه ذلك
لماذا كان في لانني اريد ان اذكر
المستمعات والمستمعين والمشاهدات
والمشاهدين ان بفضل التناصف وصلت
الانتخابات البلديه لتمثيليه النساء الى
48% وان هذه الارقام تاتي بعد عشر سنوات
نعم منذ ثوره تونسيه وبعد نضال كبير لماذا
تاريخي لان هناك تشريع وهناك اطار كامل
وقع تحضيره
كيف
لجعل النساء يتراجعن عن المشاركه تقول
السيده ليلى هناك عزوف
طبعا هناك عزوف طبعا الخطاب السياسي لم
يشجع النساء
الخطاب الثاني الخطاب هو الخطاب السياسي
الذي تواجه اليوم لم يفرز الرجال باي قالك
القوانين لم تعطي للرجال اي اي يعني
اي اسبقيه وافضليه هل كان لابد لها ان
تفعل ذلك مع خطابات الرنانه لم تساعد
النساء هل كان لها ذلك عندما يقع التراجع
عن تناصه اقرر منذ اكثر من ست سنوات في
2016 وهو ما افرز 48% في البلديه وهو ما
جعل عديد النساء مثل السيد الذي حديد ونحن
ان يكونن في معطى لك الحياه السياسيه
نقطه مهمه بالنسبه
ايضا الخطاب السياسي لا يؤثر في التشريعات
فعلا ولكنه يؤثر في العقول
لابد من خطاب تنويري لابد من عمليه تغيير
عقول كنا نحن بصدادها من خلال التناصف ومن
خلال ترسانه قانونيه كامله لتمكين النساء
ولفرض المساواه اليوم لم تفرض المساواه
ونحن مجرد مزكيات نحن نرفض ان نكون ذكيات
نحن مجرد مذكرات صيدليه حداد تقول ضيفتي
في الجانب المقابل وكثيرون صراحه يحملون
المسؤوليه بشكل واضح اليوم للقانون
للانتخاب الجديد الذي استحدثه الرئيس
والغي بموجبه مبدا التناصف بين رثاء
الرجال والنساء في المجالس المنتخب ما من
شانه وفق همم
البعض ان يكرس مو وصفت بدنيه المراه همم
البعض يؤكد ان القانون او القوانين بشكل
عام بالاضافه الى الخطاب السياسي الذي
تحدثت عنه ضيفتي لابد منه لتغيير العقليات
وان التناصف والتمييز الايجابي لابد منهما
لضمان مكتسبات المراه وحقوقها كيف تردين
على ضيفه يا سيد اهلاوي
طبعا اذا كنا نتحدث عن اراده سياسيه فلنقل
للامانه
وبموضوعيه انا رئيس قيس سعيد كان اكثر
اراده من بقيه الاحزاب السياسيه التي كانت
في البرلمان حيث تقلدت المراه اليوم اكثر
من 24% من تواجدها في همم يعني همم معناها
مهام
كوزيرات وتقلد رئيسه حكومه لاول مره في
تونس وفي الدول العربيه ولكن نجد كذلك انا
من يتحدثون عن الحداثه ان في همم في
القانون الانتخابي القديم كان التناسق
يعني مجرد تزيين لمشهد هو تاسيس المراه في
همم في المجلس النواب اكثر منها تكون لها
الكفاءه بالشكل الذي يمكنها من تواجد
حقيقي وفاعل داخل همم يعني الحياه
السياسيه واكبر دليل ان حتى بعض الاحزاب
السياسيه لا تجد ان من يكون في القائمه هو
دائما الرجل وبالتالي المراه دائما تكون
الثانيه في القائمه وبالتالي تكون خدودها
اقل اعتقد ان التشريعات انا معه التشريعات
ان هي دائما الدافع والرافع لتواجد المراه
ولكن القانون الانتخابيه هذه هو قانون على
الافراد وبالتالي هناك حريه للمراه او
للرجل في ان يتقدم في الترشح داخل الدوائر
الانتخابيه ولا يمكن بحال من الاحوال من
الناحيه القانونيه ان نطفي عليه التناظر
فهناك بعض الدوائر مثلا تجد فيها ثلاث
نساء واربع نساء وترشحات وكذلك قد تجد في
دائره اخرى او رجال فقط مترشحين الاسباب
الاسباب هي اسباب عديده اعتقد ان تراجع
المراه ليس لي فقط تشريعات كما يتحدثون
وانما الى الواقع الذي تعيشه تونس منذ
2001 جيش الى يومنا هذا حتى النسائيه
والدفاع عن المراه للاسف الشديد
رقم تواجد للتشريعات فان المراه اصبحت
دائما تتناول كضحيه وليست كمواطنه وحينما
اعطاها القانون القانون الانتخابي اليوم
ان تمارس حقها كمواطنه لها نفس الحقوق
والواجبات وان تقوم
بارادتها ان تترشح فانها رفضت الترشح
والعزوف هذا نعمره همم معناها دليل قاطع
على ان المراه كذلك مسلمه بشكل او باخر في
عدم التواجد في المشهد السياسي وهذا يرجع
الى ان حتى نزلاتنا نحن كنساء في همم في
مزيد كسب همم ودعم تواجد للمراه في الحياه
السياسيه ما زال فيه كثير من المعوقات
ترجع الى المجتمع التونسي بالرغم ما نتحدث
عنه عن الحدثيه فهو محافظ بامتياز دور
القبيله والعشيره التي تميز الرجل عن
المراه دور المناخ الانتخابي الذي فيه
المال السياسي
بالتالي المراه قد تجد عديد الصعوبات في
جمع التزكيات وفي ممارستها احقها كمواطنه
تونسيه ان تدافع عن حقها وعن خيارها ان
تكون بالمجلس النواب وكذلك للاسف الشديد
هو عدم تنقيح القانون عدد 58 فيما يعتبر
بالعنف ضد المراه السياسيه الذي استفحل في
المشهد منذ سنوات ولم يجد لباب او ابواب
التشريعات في البرلمان السابق اي التنقيح
لهذه القوانين حتى يحمي المراه من نهشها
على المجال المجسات التواصل الاجتماعي
اعتقد ان الازمه تتجاوز قيس سعيد لان
اعتبره بذلك موقف سياسي وليس موقف حقوقي
بقدر ما هو هو الوضع الحقيقي للمراه
التونسيه وما تعيشه ك- سياسيه وقياديه في
الاحزاب السياسيه التي تتغنى بدور المراه
ولكن لا تجدها فاعله كقياديه سياسيه في
صفوف الاماميه وكذلك همم كذ حتى نعم طيب
المقاطعه اليس في القانون الانتخابي الذي
ربما الحالي الذي لا يقبل مبدا التناسق
ولكن ايضا في المراه نفسها وفي طبيعه
المجتمع والمساله همم
تتجاوز حتى الرئيس سيد احلام بسروال
الكاتب العمل جمعيه التونسي نساء
الديمقراطيات تعاقدين
لانها منذ ثلاثه ايام فقد قامت بتصريح
انها اعتبرت ان القانون الانتخابي ظلم
النساء
ولم يعطيهن حقهم منذ ثلاثه ايام فقط لكان
لك تصريح في نعم في هذا الايطار موجود على
شبكات التواصل وكنت ساعدت بهذا التصريح
لاني اعتبر انها كانت تعتبر ان 15% فقط هو
تراجع وانه لم يكن هناك اراده حقيقيه وان
لابد من النظارات لماذا لابد من صيدليه
يعني هذا تعليق كان لابد من النضال لي
المح على حقوقنا والاكتساب ايضا مساحات
لماذا نكتسب مساحات ان كنا ان كنت تؤمنن
فعلا اننا كنساء لسنا كفايه لسنا يعني
جديرات بالدفاع عن حقوقنا كيف يمكن اليوم
بعد كل هذه النضلات ان يقع التشكيك انا
اسفه اقولها يعني ان يقع التشكيك من جديد
في جداره النساء لم يقل احد اننا ضد وصول
النساء
خورات
هذا اولا ثانيا السيده ليلى لو سمحت خليني
نكمل ان النقطه المهمه بالنسبه ليا انه
انت اليوم تقولين انه من تقسي سياسي
مستحيل لماذا انه لماذا لا يمكن ان يكون
منطق سياسي هو منطق حقوقي بالاساس نحن
ندافع عن حقوق الانسانيه والحقوق السياسيه
للنساء تونس سلقت منذ 2017 منذ 2017
في التقرير الدوري الشامل لتونس هناك
توصيتين توصيه الاولى من اوصى مجلس حقوق
الانسان السلطات التونسيه بتعزيز مشاركه
النساء في دوائر صنع القرار وفي المناصب
القياديه وتمكينهم من الاطلاع بادوار في
جميع المجالس وتوسيع مشاركتهن في مواقع
صنع القرار في المجالات السياسيه والعامه
اذا نحن متفقات انها توصيات الدولي انها
ايضا اراده من النشويات ومن النساء تونس
ان تتواجدنا في شان الحكم
واهم شيء
بالضبط لهنا السؤال كيف لنا اليوم ان نشكك
بقدره النساء النساء قادرات مواطنات
كاملات لابد لهن ان يتواجدنا وليست منا
حقوقهن السياسيه ليست منه فقط اتفق معك في
كون المشهد السياسي والعنف السياسي الذي
يقع على النساء واعتقد اننا كثيرات اليوم
ان عزفنا فهن بسبب العنف السياسي المسلط
عليهن وليس لانهن يعني الاسباب الاخرى
التي ذكرتيها طيب سيد ليلى حداد قبل ان
تجيبي وتعقبي على ما ذهبت اليه ضيفه
قبل ان تجيبه
اليه ضيفه
سيد احلام ب سروال كانت قد المحت اليه ولو
نسبيه بعض النساء اليوم في تونس لديهن
انطباع بان بعضا من النساء اللوات وصلنا
الى سده الحكم الى همم مشهد سياسي الى
القرار السياسي
بصراحه خذلنا المراه اقول بعضا اخذنا
المراه التونسيه بتصريحاتهن
وبمواقفهن ولكن ان تعقبي على مذهبه اليه
ايضا ضيفتي سيد احلام بسروال
لا طبعا انا
اريد الاجابه في البدايه اولا همم
تصريحاتي هو في الجانب التناسق في
التزكيات انا ارفض يعني وسرحت بذلك الى حد
الان انا مقتنعه بما ان القانون الانتخابي
جعل الرجل والمراه متساويين في همم خوض
معركه الانتخابات
بنفس الدرجه وان كان اعتبر ان المناخ يعني
كان محافظا نوعا ما وصعب على المراه وهمم
نوعا ولكن انا ارفض ان يجعل من المراه
التناسب في التزكيات وهذا انا اراه ذات
تقليل من المراه وهذا عبرت عنها فليترك
يعني كنت اتمنى ان تكون التزكيات بدون هذا
التناسق لانه مهين كيف للمراه ان تعطي
يعني تزكي للرجل ولكن ليس لها نفس الحضره
التي ممكن ان تكون في اراد في انتخابات
باعتبار ان لا مجال في هذا القانون من
الناحيه القانونيه همم وضع التناسق على
الترشح اا على الافراد ولكن كذلك انا
اعتبر ان المراه كذلك في همم كثير من خاصه
في البرلمان لم تنصف المراه باعتبار ان
كان بامكان تنقيح العديد من القوانين
وخاصه القوانين المتعلقه بالعنف السياسي
ضد المراه لان هي اعتبر هذا الموضوع مهم
جدا هو من بين المواضيع المهمه التي جعلت
عزوف المراه على
خوض التجربه والدفاع عن حقوقها كمواطنه
تونسيه وليست كضحيه انا دائما يعني في كل
تدخلاته على المستوى الوطني او المستوى
الدولي احاول ان اقدم المراه باعتبارها
مواطنه نفس الحقوق ونفس الواجبات من الرجل
وان لها الكفاءه اكبر دليل ان نسبه
التعليم الجامعي لان المراه ونجاحها متف
على رجل بنسبه عاليه وعاديه جدا وبالتالي
من حقها ان تكون كمواطنه وليس منا من
الرجل او بدافع ان نعطي لها تشريعات لتسهل
لها الولوج الى همم معناها لتكون مقلده او
صاحبه قرار سياسي في السواع السلطه
التنفيذيه او البرلمان بل انها كمواطنه
للاسف الى حد الان فان كل الموضوعين
وحقيقيين في معالجه الامر وهو ان الى حد
الان المجتمع التونسي لم يتقبل فكره ان
التونسيه المراه التونسيه هي مواطنه نفس
الحقوق ونفس الواجبات لماذا
هو الدفاع في تواجدها نعم لحمايه الحقيقه
يجب ان تكون هناك اراده سياسيه بدون اراده
سياسيه بدون وعي مجتمعي لا يمكن للمراه ان
تصل الى المراتب كقياديه في الاحزاب
السياسيه
للحديد قبل ان نختم مع ضيفه السيد احلام
بوس الواير ما الحل وهل يمكن تدارك ان
اليوم باختصار شديد
ام انه بالنسبه لك عفوا
معك سيد احلام بشده حداد هل هل ما الحل هل
يمكن تدارك النقاصه نظرك في هذا المجال
المساله التناسق لا لا توجد نقاس باختصار
شديد لو سمحت
لا الحل هو ان تعود نذاله المراه ان مع
التحركات
من اجل الدفاع عن حق المراه
وستكون للاسف الشديد نسبه ضعيفه وظيفه جدا
وقد تنقص من 12% الى 7% او 6% باعتبار ان
الحملات الانتخابيه ستكون شرسه جدا في وضع
انتخابي فيه المال السياسي
يعني القبليه والعشائريه ودور المراه التي
تكون منقوص وهذا سيدفع بالنساء والمنظمات
الوطنيه للدفاع من جديد على همم مكانه
المراه سياسيه في همم في في تونس
همم
شكرا همم قالت المراه لم تنصف المراه ما
الحل بالنسبه لك ايضا سيد اهلا بك سروال
وهل يمكن تدارك باختصار
ايه قالت لابد ان
تعودنا مستمره صيدليه قبل قبل 2011 بعد
2011 وغدا ايضا نحن نرفض هذا المسار
الانتخابي بهذه الشاكله لانه اقصاء للنساء
نحن ندين ايضا الخطابات السياسيه اليوم
التي تاتي من اعلى هرم من السلطه ولا تكرس
مكتسبات النساء ونرفض التشريعات التي ضربت
بمكتسباتنا وطناقضت مع الفصل
5122 هناك تناقض يحرك اليوم السلطه تناقض
بين الدستور 2022 في الفصل 51 الذي يؤكد
على انه سوف يدرس مكتسبات النساء وقانون
الانتخابات التي جاء غالبا التناصف وهو
احد مكتسباتنا وتعود كل شكر كل شكر هذا ما
نتمناه شكرا جزيلا لكم على هذه الحلقه
الكاتب العمل جمعيه التونسيه النساء
الديات الديمقراطيات وكل الشكر جزيلا لك
ايضا حداد
والقياديه في حركه الشعب كنتم معنا في
فقره وجهنا لوجه شكرا جزيلا لكم